so today is a webinar about using the
bio script to create federal grant
applications or as part of your federal
grant application Jerry Bailey is going
to be presenting and sherry so I'm going
to go ahead and turn it over to you
thank you Peter
again my name is sherry and I would like
to thank you again for joining us our
objective today is to create a
biographical sketches for NIH NSF and
do-e these are all United States federal
grant applications
so before we really get started let's
have a quick poll one of the things that
we would like to know is which US
federal agencies that you will be using
well it looks great it looks like the
majority of you will be using NIH
there's quite a few of you here who will
be using NSS biosketches
so 2% other agencies and some people
haven't decided if they're going to
submit or plan their submissions
great so let's go ahead and jump right
in try a CD and my bibliography are part
of a free profile service that is part
of my NCBI which is offered by the NIH
the National Institutes of Health
benefits of a free entity I account
includes professional profile tools and
other great features to use with NCBI
services we will be providing links at
the end of our presentation if you would
like to learn more but today our focus
is my bibliography profiles gets
creation so what exactly is science dd
sciencv allows you to document your
education employment research activities
and incorporate your publications your
honors Advanced Research as well as
other professional contributions a few
benefits include the ability to leverage
data from existing systems that you may
already be using like working reduce
administrative burden by creating a
document one and then copying copying
and editing that information for
multiple grant applications and taking
comfort in knowing that the document
will appear to the government standard
when you create a biosketch you have
three options like from scratch
duplicating an existing document and
modifying or using an external source
like orchid to import citations and
education
my bibliography is a reference tool that
helps you save your citations from
PubMed if you do not have citations in
PubMed don't worry you can manually
upload an RAF file created by your
citation manager and enter the citation
information using the built in templates
an additional benefit of using my
bibliography is that you can generate a
public URL to share your bibliography
with others
now that we have a general understanding
of the tools used to create a biosketch
let's briefly touch upon how to create
an account to access science CD there
are two ways NSF users you may want to
directly go in google science CD using
your favorite web browser from here if
you have an Erie Commons account or NSF
credentials you just simply select the
appropriate icon and provide your login
information if you have an institution
that is an incoming partner or would
prefer to use Google for example you
would click see more third-party sign-in
options the final selection is an NCBI
icon where you can create a native
account to login directly to the site
which allows you to use the forgot my
password feature
the second way to access your my NCBI
account and science CD is to go directly
to PubMed gov or any other NCBI page and
click the log in link located on the top
right which will provide similar
creation and login options after your
account has been created or at any time
you can link additional third-party
account such as orchid er a common HRA
which is the health Research Alliance
and or NSF you may also link your Google
account or your institution is explicit
which will provide you additional ways
to access your single account making is
as simple as once you free to link your
account click on your username which
will be located on the top right of the
screen locate the linked accounts fields
and click the Change button locate and
select your institution or Google and
provide additional credentials another
feature located in your account setting
is delegation as a researcher you may
not always have time to manage your
account my NCBI users can grant access
to others to edit and create documents
and sciencv as well as add edit and
delete citations and model biography now
it's time for a quick poll I would like
to know how you will be using the
delegation within the my NCBI account
okay it looks like the majority of you
you create and maintain it yourself and
it's equally split that you create and
maintain it for someone else this is a
great option for you to use to access
this feature again you would put your
user name located on the top right you
would add a delegate type in the email
address of the person managing your
account and click OK the delegate will
receive an email which invites them to
create their own account in order to
manage yours
now that we have the administrative
piece out of the way let's begin
creating a biosketch the first time you
access sciencv
you will be taken to the create a new
document page the form will allow you to
give the document a title determine the
format of the biosketch select your data
source decide if you will be starting
with a blank document duplicating an
existing document or using an external
source like orchid now remember orchid
will automatically import your
biographical and citation data into the
biosketch finally you're going to
determine if you would like to share
your document using a URL or keep it
private you always have the ability to
change the setting at any time once you
hit create you are ready to enter your
information into the field all
biosketches have the following
components in common the profile name or
title that you created on the previous
page the profile type either NIH NIH
fellowship IES or NSF
the last time you updated the file
the ability to share and over on the
right download options and OMB
information please note NSF document the
biosketch and the current and pending
support only have PDF and XML versions
available which is a requirement and NSF
proposal and award policies and
procedures guide the next field is
already entered with your information
which includes your name and any length
accounts such as the era Commons NSF or
orchid if available
which brings us to the first section
which brings us to the first section of
Education
although the titles may appear different
in Section A for NSF request the same
data here you will enter your degree and
training information
once the information has been added the
summary will appear on the screen with
the ability to delete or edit any entry
this is an example for NSF but the
education and training for NIH and IES
biosketches
appear the same
so you're probably wondering what
happened to section a for NIH and IES
biosketches
here a consists of a personal statement
with the option to include for
peer-reviewed publications it's
important to note that a lot of the
information can be reused but there are
subtle differences between NIH and IES
from the actual NSF biosketch
Section B requests employment and
appointment information which are also
similar the NIH and IES requests
additional information
always remember to read the directions
provided beneath each section so you are
providing exactly what is requested
here's an example of Section B for NIH
and IES
here's the example of section B for NSF
Section C is where you're able to
provide a description in your own words
your contributions to science and add
supporting citations you will notice in
the Box the ability to add a link to
include the complete citation list of
published works from my bibliography
which will appear in your downloaded
document for NIH biosketches
as well as IES
Section C for NSF biosketch this
provides a description of acceptable and
unacceptable product and citations to be
included there is also an additional
unique element to NSF which includes the
ability to add additional citations
for section C
all of the biosketches have an ad
citation box that looks and operates the
exact same the first tab is my
bibliography
beneath that in the blue box you will
see add citations F citations will take
you directly to PubMed in order to add
citations to your my bibliography when
you click on go to my bibliography it
will take you to yes you guessed it my
bibliography from here you are able to
again as your citations from PubMed as
citations from a file which includes RAF
from either examples are in note as well
as refworks or add citations manually
once that is complete you are able to go
back by clicking your username located
on the top right and selecting dashboard
you may have noticed that the dashboard
looks a little bit different from the
first time you saw it yes you're able to
customize the dashboard to either
collapse move or high windows if you
wish to restore any of the item click
the customize page on this link and
select the items to restore now let's
continue with a biosketch by either
clicking directly on the document or
clicking the manage sciencv
link once we are actually back into the
biosketch itself
it would look like this one information
is added into my bibliography if you
have linked your orchid information the
second tab will populate as well we
would like to know how you currently use
orchid if you could take another brief
poll with them we would appreciate it
and it looks like the majority of you
you do use Orkut so those of you who are
not familiar with orchid it's a
nonprofit organization that provides the
unique identifiers that distinguishes
you from other researchers so you
usually put this on your publications
but you can also use Orkut in order to
put patents products that you've created
as well moving on sessions be for NIH
and IES is where you are able to
associate your wart Awards and bio
sketches for the NIH fellowship and
biosketch Awards ESCA last performances
can be added which is towards the bottom
for NSF users you will use a completely
different form which is also part of
science TV which is current and pending
support this is where you're going to
add your awards as well as any in-kind
contribution
Section D for NSF includes synergistic
activities which provides a box for free
text once the information is entered you
have the ability to hover over the entry
and change the position of the text
delete and edit information
once you would verify the information
and are ready to save or print the PDF
links are available on the top and lower
right-hand side as well as the XML for
all users the only difference is again
NSF users are not able to download the
Word document if you find that you've
made an error you can go back into this
document make the corrections and resave
or print
so in summary sciencv allows you to
create and store multiple documents from
scratch from data source such as orchid
and you're able to also copy your form
from an existing biosketch or CMPs form
which is NSM you are able to output your
PDF or Word documents depending on which
one you're using or demand and you have
delegates that you can manage your
account documentation is about sciencv
my bibliography and my NCBI can be found
here also at the bottom is an email
address where we welcome feedback
suggestions questions and just general
help if you are needed
let's open the floor up to any
additional question thanks sherry Rana
are there are there any questions
actually
so sherry one of the participants in
this particular webinar is really
interested in using a biosketch but
actually goes directly to find funding
sources NIH anis and NSF is it possible
through sciencv to create separate
biosketches for NIH and an exception
what if they're actually applying to two
or three grant programs from either of
these institutions can you use my
bibliography and sciencv to create
multiple biosketches well within NSF
you're able to use the PDF which they
supply on their form as well as the BIOS
gets within science CD is something
that's going to be mandated by NSF
beginning October 5th the fact that you
can interchange the information because
each policy in a SEF as well as NIH has
their own particular guideline that's
why there are slight differences but at
least we do give you the ability to
share that information in order to
create multiple biosketches excellent a
number of people are interested in
organs specifically and they know that
you can import or give citations into my
bibliography to be used for science TV
can you also do the universe take my
bibliography and reroute them back to
organ is there a better way to do it one
more fact if any other I'm actually at
this time no we just import their
information we are looking at other ways
that they can also retrieve information
from us in order to make it better for
our users okay and as a follow up on
that is there Minoo is there a direct
pump from orchid into science city is
there the possibility to import or
export bibtex formats in my bibliography
do you happen to know about that
actually we're looking at that way as
well if you would take your suggestions
your suggestion and write to info at
NCBI you know NLM's at nih gov the more
documentation that we have that this is
what people want the faster that we can
probably get this into production great
you may not know what is there any
particular place that provides advice
for good quality biosketches what
funders are looking for i imagine that
each funding agency might have its own
documentation but there are a number of
people who have asked about guidance
what would you recommend in terms of
them finding guidance about how to
create a biosketch for a particular
agency or best practices and things like
that i would definitely go back to each
agency to ask your questions because
there are specific things that they are
looking for here's a here's a question
if you have a current biosketch and want
to import your biosketch into sciencv is
that possible it is not possible at this
time but it was definitely something
that I am taking note of and will put it
in front of our development team and
finally in terms of exporting biochem
sketches are there different formats for
exporting like you've finally created
your biosketch for NIH or for NSF what
formats does sciencv export their
biosketch ISM okay so you have the
ability to for all of them either PDF as
well as an XML file for IES as well as
NIH biosketches you also have the
additional Word document that you are
able to manipulate okay great thank you
very much for attending our webinar and
we hope you have a great and safe rest
of the day thank you thanks Ryan thanks
sherry this is Peter Cooper again thanks
everybody and I'm going to go ahead and
end the webinar